put my stuff in jello again hey what's
up freaks out there
Cody Harrison Reese you might recognize
these from some Comedy Central videos
like Nick man in the sand and Luke took
my butt plug and since it's Comedy
Central's birthday today and it's also
April Fool's I thought I might hit him
where it hurts of a classic jello prank
from one of my favorite number one
television shows the television show the
office
Pam is always like where's Jim I think
something terrible happened to Jim
Steve Carell is like um no more paper
for you so those are all really funny
anyways I snuck into Comedy Central last
night took a piss in their bathroom and
I helped me that I stole some awesome
stuff here check this movie out green
light red light green light red light I
don't think so
so this stapler from the main paper guy
at Comedy Central he's a great guy I
kind of feel bad about taking that
because he has a hard time in a hard job
all right I'm gonna show you guys how to
do this classic freakin Frank I'm gonna
put all this stuff in jello I'm gonna go
back to Comedy Central surprise my
friends and I can't wait to see the
stupid look on their faces okay you know
what you can be a witness
can you reprimand him please how do you
know it was me this is a super easy
recipe anyone can make it at home now
first step you just gotta start with
some cold water next thing you're gonna
use is a packet of gelatin or ants come
on right in with them no please why what
did I do
we're not to pay attention to those
little screams next step here is we're
gonna get some boil in hot water all
right if you can't boil water this
recipe might not be for you sure those
little guys up that's good mm-hmm all
right now that we've added our boiling
water we're gonna go ahead and let this
set in the fridge for about three
episodes of The Office or Dwight and Pam
finally gonna hook up well Mike we'll
find the paper we'll say something let's
put it in the fridge that's my staple no
no no do not take it out if to eat it
out of there all right
Toby and Pam who would have freaking
thought huh next thing you got to do
here take a stapler any stapler will do
this one doesn't work so that's good for
us now we got some more cold water this
stuff here is pure its vitality okay
open this guy up here we got another
packet of gelatin just kind of the same
processes we did
you remember that don't you just give it
a little tap arou nothing says I love
you like a nice little tapper room it's
not my door says pour that guy in there
oh yeah hey yeah now we're gonna put
this baby back in the icebox to cool
down while that's cool i watch a little
bit more of the office work on some of
those pictures it's great I guess what
I'm most concerned with is damage to
company property that's a good one okay
we've got our Joe all frickin mold it up
ready to go staplers like take a little
plate right here you could serve a baby
on this but we're just using it for
flipping okay 1 2 3 it's a flipper okay
oh dang dude call me the frickin pizza
monster dude cuz I crushed that dude
alright I think I might have done a
pretty good job here okay I'm a regular
old Jimmy Halpern I'm going down to
Scranton to show them what they got
let's bring this the Comedy Central show
my friends let the fun thing I did was
okay see ya hey what's up jiggly
wigglies here we are at Comedy Central
Joe's gonna gone to smush town USA but
you know what they say when life gives
you lemons it's time to pitch TV shows
so let's go inside
[Music]
it's a break check out better camera
goddamn filming me this is a prank I'm
sorry who are you um I don't know you
might don't call me freaking office
prank master freaking 101 here where's
that come on
you don't think it's this freaking funny
dude Jesus God
oh hey wait my cellos in there but yeah
classic Tobi in classic Jim
[Music]